endlich nachdem cremesprecherpest Kopf
verkündet hatte dass die
Entnazifizierung und Demilitarisierung
der Ukraine im Rahmen der russischen
spezialoperation ja quasi abgeschlossen
sei die alten Waffen der Ukraine aus
sowjetischen so gut wie aufgebraucht und
eben durch westliche Waffen ersetzt
worden wären konnte Wladimir
vladimirovic Putin endlich zur
endnazifizierung Russland schreiten sein
erster weiser Schritt dabei die
Auflösung der Gruppe Wagner der
Präsident der Russischen Föderation hat
wohl nicht vergessen dass diese brutale
Söldnertruppe nicht aus Jungs und
Dollerei oder Liebe zur musiknach
Richard Wagner benannt ist nein ihr
Gründer und gehen ein strammer Neonazi
hat sie ganz bewusst nach dem glühenden
an diese mieten und Lieblingskomponisten
Adolf Hitlers wenn man
die White Power Söldner die auf der
ganzen Welt für rassistische
Unterdrückung kämpfen laut das
entstehungsmythos der Gruppe benutzt ein
ehemaliger aspektionssoldaten namens mit
Tribut Ken Wagner als Rufzeichen als er
2014 im dornbas kämpfte und Kinder von
vielen als operativer Befehlshaber der
vaginagruppe angesehen wird hat entlang
seiner Schlüsselbeine ss-runnentattoos
viele Gründungsmitglieder von Wagner
gehören auch der Ultra nationalistischen
und weiße über menschengruppierung
russische reichsbewegung an nun denn
Wladimir vladimirovic endlich also mal
eine Entnazifizierung die ihren Namen
auch verdient hätte wenn es denn
wirklich darum gegangen wäre denn
natürlich ist es Putin vollkommen
schnuppe ob Vagina oder das Militär von
Neonazis durch solche sind wichtig ist
nur dass diese Leute für ihn kämpfen
loyal und seit neuestem vor allem
kostengünstig denn genau das war auch
der Hauptgrund warum ist überhaupt zu
dieser ganzen Geschichte kam er erinnert
euch vielleicht noch dunkel da war am
vergangenen Wochenende irgendwas los in
Russland und verzeiht mir dass ich in
diesem Video noch etwas sarkastischer
bin als sonst aber wenn einen diese evil
Clowns schon die ganze Nacht wach halten
und dann nach ein paar Stunden wieder
alles vorbei zu sein scheint will ich
wenigstens noch nachträglich meinen Spaß
haben und diesen natürlich mit euch
teilen wer jetzt jedoch denkt er würde
nach Pre goschens plötzlich im Putsch
Abbruch auf all den eilig besorgten
popcornvorräten sitzen bleiben der
erdgewaltigt
am Ende dieses Videos werdet ihr genau
verstehen warum dies erst der Auftakt
war und vielleicht der Anfang vom Ende
Vladimir Putins aber eins nach dem
anderen seine kleine innere russische
spezialoperation um Wagner klein zu
kriegen ist ja erstmal gehörig nach
hinten losgegangen ihr vorläufiges
Ergebnis war dass genau 484 Tage nach
Beginn der drei Tage spezialoperation in
der Ukraine das Regime von Wladimir
Putin mit einem Putschversuch
konfrontiert wurde und dieser die großen
Schwächen eines Landes offenbart das
gehörig ins Trudeln geraten ist noch
Ende Februar 2022 glaubten viele
inklusive so illustra Persönlichkeiten
wie FDP-Minister Christian Lindner das
Vladimir Putin kurz davor stehe KF
einzunehmen und am 24 Juni 2023 war sich
der Herrscher über Russland nicht mal
mehr selbstsicher ob er überhaupt Moskau
oder vielleicht ganz Russland noch unter
seiner Kontrolle halten könnte hielten
noch 2021 selbst viele Experten die
russische Armee für die zweitstärkste
der Welt so witzigsten immer mehr
darüber dass sie 2022 nur noch die
zweitstärkste in der Ukraine sein aber
im Juni 2023 zeigte sich dass sie gar
nur die zweitstärkste in Russland selbst
ist ja schon
ärgerlich da züchtet man sich so einen
blutrünstigen Kampfhund heran damit er
die Nachbarn zerfleischt und dann geht
das Mist wie auf die geliebten Dackel im
eigenen Haus los nur weil es sie um das
bessere Fresse sie beneidet okay
auch dieser Köter der erotischerweise
selbst Ball Hotdogs verkauft hatte
Herrchen fixiert aber er ist doch
wesentlich unabhängiger als die Dackel
scheuge ungarage im auf da er sich in
Afrika auch sein eigenes Futter besorgen
kann im Gegensatz zu den Dackeln eben
die ohne ihr herrschen nicht
eigenständig lebensfähig wären und
schließlich zeigte sich dann auch Putin
als großer Tierfreund wie einst auch das
Wagner Idol Hitler und so war nach viel
Gebell ein paar zerbissenen
Spielzeugsoldaten und Möbeln der
Aufstand des zeltnersches Gregorian auch
schon wieder vorbeikommen dass der Abend
angebrochen war nicht weil er geschlagen
worden oder auch nennenswerten
Widerstand gestoßen wäre sondern weil er
mit dem ganzen Theater nach eigener
Aussage nur auf die gravierenden
Missstände in Putins Russland aufmerksam
machen aber keine russisches
Blutvergießen wollte
die Zahl der getöteten russischen
Soldaten ist drei bis viermal so hoch
wie das was nach oben gemeldet wird die
Gesamtzahl der Opfer liegt an manchen
Tagen bei bis zu 1.000 Personen es
könnte fünfmal weniger Tote geben wer
ist schuld daran dass sie gestorben sind
die Schuldigen sie diejenigen die die
Frage ob wir genug Munition haben hätten
klären müssen niemand versorgt uns mit
Nachschub es gibt keine Kontrolle
dieselbe Hysterie in der der
generalstabchef nach einem Glas Wodka
schreiben wie ein Vibe wie ein Schwein
und am Telefon die Rückkehr zu den
Stellungen fordert nun das ist ihm
gehörig gelungen auch wenn das
dahinterliegende angebliche Motiv etwas
am trostlosen Zustand Russland zu ändern
an Naivität nicht zu überbieten ist ist
ausgerechnet der Metzger von bachmut zu
einem hoffnungslosen Romantiker geworden
war das alles nichts als der Schrei
eines brutalen mörderischen Psychopaten
nach der Liebe eines anderen brutalen
mörderischen Psychopathen die Eskalation
einer über lange Zeit äußerst
praktischen aber hypertoxischen
Beziehung
die Russen kennen das aus dem Fernsehen
der Nachbarschaft oder der eigenen
Familie nur das in diesem Fall eben die
ganze Welt zugeschaut hat und weniger
Alkohol im Spiel war als allgemein
üblich die Frage die wir uns jetzt alle
Stellen ist daher was genau ist da
eigentlich passiert und warum ist es
passiert wieso habe ich gesagt das Geld
eine so große Rolle gespielt hat und
warum ist gerade darüber nicht so viel
in den Nachrichten zu hören und die
wahrscheinlich wichtigste Frage von
allen was können wir von jetzt an
erwarten was hat sich geändert für Putin
für pregorien für Russland und vor allem
für die Ukraine und Europa in diesem
Hintergrund Video werdet ihr alles
darüber erfahren was ihr wissen müsst um
die Zusammenhänge und das Gesamtbild zu
verstehen nachdem wir dieses Video
aufgenommen hatten mussten wir
feststellen dass es über eine Stunde
lang werden würde also haben wir uns
entschieden es lieber in zwei Teilen zu
veröffentlichen damit ihr die
umfangreiche Materie besser verdauen
könnt im heutigen ersten Teil werdet ihr
also alles über die genauen Hintergründe
erfahren die zur Eskalation des Konflikt
zwischen und den Kremmen geführt haben
aber schon morgen werden über den
zweiten Teil veröffentlichen indem wir
die schweren folgende Ereignisse
analysieren am besten ihr aktiviert
daher jetzt gleich das Abo Glöckchen um
es nicht zu verpassen ich garantiere
euch das am Ende kein Auge trocken
bleiben wird passt gut auf denn es gibt
einige Dinge die ihr bereits aus der
laufenden Berichterstattung und den
expertenanalysen kennt aber es gibt auch
andere die euch sicher überraschen
werden wichtig ist uns hierbei für euch
aus dem diesmal heftigen
informationsrauschen das herauszufiltern
was wirklich relevant ist den medialen
Nebel des Krieges zu lichten und euch
das klare schlüssige Bild zu vermitteln
das hinter der ganzen Geschichte steckt
sofort müssen wir euch doch darauf
hinweisen dass dieses Video von Konflikt
auf nations gesponsert wird denn wenn du
das geostrategische Pokerspiel das
trickreich und mehrdeutige Aktivieren
der großen Weltmächte risikofrei in
einem Online TV Games selbst
ausprobieren möchtest ist konfliktation
genau das richtige für dich darin
übernimmst du die Kontrolle über die
Streitkräfte einer global führenden
Nation die für ihre militärische
Expansion wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
technologische Forschung und
internationale Diplomatik Verantwort es
handelt sich um ein recht beliebtes
langzeitstrategiespiel das auf dem PC im
Webbrowser oder auf dem Handy gespielt
werden kann und bei dem in einem Match
bis zu 100 Spieler miteinander um die
globale Vorherrschaft kämpfen du baust
nach und nach deine Infrastruktur und
Streitkräfte auf und beginnst dann
Gegner zu bekämpfen und rektorium zu
beanspruchen mit den anderen
menschlichen Spielern gegen die du
online antriffst kannst du chatten und
auf diese Art eine vielfältige
Diplomatie entfalten das Konzept der
Langzeitstrategie von konflikation
erzeugt dabei eine Art bestechenden
Realismus für das langfristige Ringen um
die Weltherrschaft das Spiel enthält
zwar ein paar Gewinner Elemente ist
ansonsten jedoch für play das heißt du
kannst über den Link in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video einen vollkommen
kostenlosen Account einrichten und es
dann sowohl auf deinem Rechner als auch
beim Handy spielen und das Beste wenn du
auf den Link in der Beschreibungstext
erhältst du als Bonus 13.000 Gold in
Game Währung und einen ganzen Monat
bringen aber gratis dazu dieses Angebot
gilt nur für 30 Tage also zögere nicht
zu lange und fangen am besten noch heute
damit an deine Truppen zu mobilisieren
neue Allianzen zu schmieden und
siegreiche Schlachten zu planen so und
nun lass uns wieder schnell zum Thema
des heutigen Videos kommen was genau
steckt eigentlich hinter euch ins
Aufstand wieso ist das dazu gekommen und
welche Folgen wird er haben aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am Samstag dem 24 Juni Ihr Rasen die
Truppen meines Warlords bewaffnet
ausgerüstet und kampfbereit über
russisches Territorium um Moskau zu
erobern der krabbel in die Enge
getrieben und fassungslos versucht den
Vormarsch dieser bewaffneten Kolonne zu
stoppen indem er Barrikaden errichtet
straßensperrt und Brücken sabotiert die
russische Luftwaffe zerstört eigene
Treibstoff und Munitionsdepots um den
Vormarsch das Söldner zu stoppen aber
das alles ist vergeblich denn die
Truppen deshalb Rücken und aufhaltsam
auf die Hauptstadt vor okay meine Lieben
Zuschauer auch wenn dies wie das
Drehbuch alles eher zweitklassigen
Hollywood actions klingt und wie wir
wissen sehr schnell in eine peinliche
schmieren Komödie ableiten wird diese
Geschichte ist absolut real und spielt
sich im heutigen Russland ab wir alle
haben sie schließlich miterlebt am 23
und 24 Juni 2023 wurde das von einigen
befürchtete aber allgemein Undenkbare
Wirklichkeit ihr Gehirn in der Anführer
der wagnergruppe lieferte sich mit
Wladimir Putin das größte andrücken der
modernen der russischen Geschichte da
dieser seine Truppen seine treudos
unfähigen Verteidigungsminister scheuge
unterstellen wollte in diesem Video
werden wir euch aber nicht erklären wer
genau pregosch in est wie die
wagnergruppe funktioniert oder wie ist
überhaupt möglich ist dass er über 25
bis 50 000 Soldaten verfügt und
Russlands einzigen großen Sieg in der
Ukraine seit April 22 erringen konnte
nein das werden wir nicht tun denn das
alles haben wir euch bereits in mehreren
früheren Videos sind alle
Ausführlichkeit dargestellt ich werde
sie euch natürlich in der Beschreibung
verlinken falls ihr sie noch nicht
gesehen haben solltet denk bitte daran
unseren Kanal unbedingt mit Glöckchen zu
abonnieren um kein weiteres unsere
informativen Videos zu verpassen nur auf
diese Weise übernehmt ihr selbst die
Kontrolle über euer Sehverhalten auf
Youtube überlasse es nicht einem
untransparenten Profit getriebenen
Algorithmus aber das ist ein anderes
Thema zurück nach Russland wir werden
uns dieses Mal auf die einzigartige
Hintergrundgeschichte konzentrieren wie
er zu einem Hollywood Blockbuster als in
die Abendnachrichten passen würde aber
trotzdem zu 100% Realität ist als erstes
müssen wir klarstellen wie es überhaupt
so weit kommen konnte
[Musik]
die Spitzen der russischen Armee und der
Anführer der wagnergruppe gehen sich
seit Monaten gegenseitig an die Gurgel
und wie wir wissen tun sie das nicht
privat im Verborgenen oder Hinterzimmern
Interviews Videos und den sozialen
Medien immer wieder die Inkompetenz und
Korruption der russischen Militärs an
insbesondere von Verteidigungsminister
zeigen und generalstoffchef Valerie
Gerasdorf
und nach der Einnahme wachmut startete
das Verteidigungsministerium seinerseits
einen Plan um den wachsenden Einfluss
der wagnergruppe zu verringern am
1.7.2023 sollte Wagner aufgelöst und
entwaffnet werden alle wagnerkämpfer
sollten in die reguläre Armee
aufgenommen und die gesamte Struktur der
Kontrolle von Minister scheuco
unterstellt werden Gregorian hatte seine
Aufgabe als trouble Shooter erfüllt also
brauchte man ihn nicht mehr und stellte
und seine Truppen bis zum 1 Juli
komplett unter das Kommando des
Verteidigungsministeriums zu stellen das
war für den Oberbefehlshaber der
Wandergruppe natürlich völlig
inakzeptabel schließlich hätte das in
der Praxis nicht nur den Verlust seines
Lebenswerks und macht Apparats bedeutet
sondern in der Art entbehrlich gemacht
dass seine Liquidierung durch den Kreml
quasi zum Null Kosten Preise der
erfolgen können außerdem war sich
gregorch in der Tatsache bewusst dass
scheuburg nicht zugeben und Putin nicht
verstehen würde dass die Ukraine den
Krieg gewinnen und das ist für Russland
von nun an nur noch schlimmer werden
würde während er und Wagner weiter in
der Ukraine verblieben hätte das sowieso
das Ende bedeutet und ohne sie wäre
entweder von der Ukraine gefangen
genommen oder von liquidiert worden er
musste für diese vertragte Situation
also irgendeine Lösung finden und wie
sah diese Lösung aus nun seinem
aggressiven Führungsstil entsprechend
ging er zum Gegenangriff über er
verstärkte seine Vorwürfe der Korruption
und massiven Inkompetenz gegen das
russische Oberkommando und so
eskalierten die Spannungen zwischen den
beiden Seiten wie die Temperatur eines
Vulkans der kurz vor dem Ausbruch steht
der letzte Impuls kam am Freitag den 23
juni als Pre Goschen die russische Armee
beschuldigte die Lage seiner Truppe
angegriffen und viele Wagener Kämpfer
getötet zu haben er gab insbesondere den
russischen Verteidigungsminister Serie
voll gut die Schuld dafür und schwur
Rache und die hatte es in sich in einem
30 Minuten Video tobte sich der
wagnerführer aus unserer störte das
bisher sorgsam gehe aktiv des Krems
komplett er räumte gegenüber sein
verdutzten Zuschauern ein dass der Krieg
gegen die Ukraine keinerlei
Rechtfertigung hat er sagte die
russischen regierungselierten sein
nichts als ein inkompetenter und
korrupter Haufen die ganze
spezialoperation der Ukraine mitsamt
ihrer Begründung seit komplett
inszeniert worden um die Taschen der
kleinen und großen Bosse im
staatsoperation für
[Musik]
das war natürlich nur der Anfang der
nächste Schritt war die Besetzung der
Stadt Rostock am Donner einer Großstadt
mit über einer Million Einwohner und
einem absolut wichtigen militärischen
Zentrum für die russischen
Kriegsanstrengungen in der Ukraine dies
war sicherlich eine Grenze an der ist
kein Zurück mehr gehabt
und Freunde werden Fragen dass ich
darauf vorbereitet der Rostock zu
besetzen gab der russische
Generalstaatsanwalt am Samstag morgen
bekannt das gegenregion gegen
bewaffneten Aufstandes ermittelt wird
einige Stunden später Verwandte sich
dann Wladimir Putin selbst Animation und
beschuldigte sein ehemaligen Verbündeten
ein Verräter zu sein er versprach die
Verantwortlichen so hart wie möglich zu
bestrafen alle konnten es sehen und
hören Mutter
natürlich stand erhöhepunkt dieses
armdrückens unter Arschlöchern noch
bevor kurz darauf bestätigten die aus
Neonazis und allen Arten von Kriminellen
zusammengesetzten truppengruppe was sie
bereits angekündigt hatten sie waren auf
dem Weg nach Moskau und sie nannten
ihren Wochenende pathetisch einen Marsch
der Gerechtigkeit und wohlgemerkt das
war kein Witz obwohl Wagners Operationen
keinen großen Einsatz von Truppen und
Ausrüstung Vornamen musste der Kevin
Pläne aus der Sowjet ihrer aktivieren um
die Hauptstadt zu verteidigen einfach
verrückt
[Musik]
in Erwartung der Ankunft Truppen wurden
Barrikaden errichtet Straßen blockiert
drücken alle verfügbaren Truppen
eingesetzt laut Plan sollte Moskau unter
dem Schuss der vierten Garde Panzer
Division der zweiten motorisierten
gerade die Vision stehen insgesamt
schätzungsweise 6000 Mann hinzu kam
Einheiten der Gruß betzner-spezialheiten
die Nationalgarde und die Polizei
trotzdem stellt sich die Frage ob diese
Einheiten über ausreichend Ausbildung
und Kampf Erfahrung verfügen um 5000 auf
dem Schlachtfeld gestählte Profis sollte
das verstorben nun ist endlich musste
diese Frage nicht beantwortet werden
[Musik]
wie alle bist wurde am späten Nachmittag
als die Vagina Kolonne schon sehr nah an
die Hauptstadt gerückt war eine Art
Waffenstillstand verkündet bring euch
ins Männer kehrten um nachdem sie
Hunderte von Kilometern ohne Gegenwert
zurückgelegt und sechs russische Armee
Hubschrauber und ein russisches Armee
Flugzeug abgeschossen hatten tja und
trotzdem hat anschließend Russland
jegliche Anschuldigungen gegen sie wegen
Rebellion vom Tisch gewischt stellt euch
mal vor sowas wäre in einer normalen
Start mit einem normalen politischen
System passiert nicht in einem Mafia
Staat könnte sich zum Beispiel
Blackwater CEO Prince leisten einen
Feldzug gegen washingt zu führen und
Armee Flugzeuge abzuschießen und könnt
ihr euch vorstellen er würde
anschließend begnadigt werden allein
dies veranschaulich schon in welchem
Zustand sich Russland überhaupt befindet
aber obwohl wir wissen dass man Russland
nicht mit den gängigen politischen
Maßstäben betrachten kann gibt es ein
paar Fragen die wir uns stellen müssen
warum hat sich bringt euch einen
überhaupt auf ein solches Abenteuer
eingelassen was bedeutet dieser Bus
versucht wirklich weiß überhaupt einer
warum hat Wagner seinen Marsch der
Gerechtigkeit gestoppt obwohl sie doch
so nah an Moskau waren und ihre
Hauptforderungen nicht erfüllt worden
und die wohl wichtigste Frage von allen
was bedeutet das alles für die Zukunft
Russlands der Ukraine und Europas also
lasst uns die Ärmel hochkrempeln und los
geht's
eines vorhergesagten Chaos
wir haben hier bei Sozialpolitik in
vielen Videos darüber berichtet Jenseits
alle Propaganda ist es nun mal so dass
der Krieg in der Ukraine für Russland
einen kolossales Desaster ist so gut wie
niemand in Russland gewinnt dadurch
etwas und die meisten verlieren am Ende
sogar sehr viel die Wirtschaft des
Landes leidet und die Zukunft Prognosen
sind so düster wie nie zuvor die Russen
sind jetzt viel mehr isoliert und die
Meinungsfreiheit wurde weiter
eingeschränkt die großen Oligarchen
haben ihrerseits ein Vermögen und ein
großes Stück Freiheit verloren sagen wir
einfach dass ihr luxuriöse Lebensstil
bei dem sie in der ganzen Welt
herumreisen leben und sich unterhalten
lassen ernsthaft beeinträchtigt wurde
aber all diese Opfer sind natürlich
nicht mit dem zu vergleichen was die
Menschen in der Ukraine erleiden müssen
trotzdem seit dem Beginn des Krieges gab
es gewaltige Verluste auf beiden Seiten
russland hat einen großen Teil seiner
militärischen Stärke verloren und
befindet sich nun zu allem Übel auch
noch in der Defensive der ukrainische
Gegenangriffe verläuft zwar langsamer
als von einigen erwartet aber er trifft
die bereits erschöpften russischen
Truppen extrem hart und wohlgemerkt das
sagen nicht nur wir das kommt von selbst
der Mann der seit Monaten das medial
präsenteste Gesicht der russischen
kriegseinstrengungen ist schaut es euch
an
diese ungeschnitten
[Musik]
aber es geht nicht nur um gregorien
sicher ist dass die Daten die jetzt
verfügbar wären zu keinerlei Optimismus
einladen für Russland so lassen Angaben
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte selbst
weitgehend bestätigt hat darauf
schließen dass die russischen Verluste
nicht nur weitaus höher sind als die
ukrainischen sondern doppelt so hoch wie
die Verluste zu Beginn der Offensive in
Person im Sommer 22 und das gleiche gilt
für die Verluste bei der Ausrüstung und
ich weiß was ihr jetzt denkt Daten aus
der Ukraine machst du witzemark du hast
doch selbst mal gesagt die Ukraine würde
zur Vorbereitung dagegen Offensive eine
massive Desinformationskampagne fahren
also alles pure Propaganda ja natürlich
es besteht die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
dies der Fall sein könnte aber überlegt
mal wenn die aktuellen ukrainischen
Zahlen erfunden werden müsste dies auch
für den Sommer 22 gelten allerdings
gehen eben nicht nur die Angaben der
westlichen Nachrichtendienste in dieser
Richtung nein auch kriegerischen der
Mann der sich dazu entschlossen hat die
russische Militärführung durch die reine
Wahrheit unter Druck zu setzen
als Menschen
deshalb sind wir uns noch nicht mal so
sehr die konkreten Daten wichtig sondern
der Trends den der Krieg folgt aber
keine Angst das alles werden wir in
einem kommenden Video hier bei Politik
im Detail auseinandernehmen also nicht
vergessen und weiter im Text denn
wichtig ist für uns vor allem dass dies
nichts Neues darstellt
seit Monaten schon wirft der Anführer
der wagnergruppe hochrangigen russischen
kriegsmanagern vor ihn nicht mit der
nötigen Munition und Ausrüstung versorgt
zu haben und er gab ihnen die Schuld für
die schweren russischen Verluste und
wisst ihr was das ist etwas absolut
grundlegendes das militärische Versagen
in der Ukraine zwingt einerseits zu
suchen nach Schuldigen andererseits
entstehen dadurch Risse ins System die
viele ausnutzen wollen um ihre Macht zu
vergrößern und genau das scheint
pregorit in den letzten Monaten getan zu
haben als er sich damals bei
gegenwärtigt hat das mit der aktuellen
Strategie und dieser zermürbis und
Verschleißrate der Krieg für Russland
nicht zu gewinnen und mit einem
kolossalen Debatte für das ganze Land
unseren Esstisch mit Enten wird Finger
an an einer exe Strategie für sich zu
strecken einerseits wollte er sich von
seiner Verantwortung reinwaschen und mit
dem Finger auf andere zeigen bevor diese
mit den Finger auf ihn zeigen auf der
anderen Seite will er an der Macht und
vor allem am Leben bleiben und diese
beiden Dinge sind in Russland stark
voneinander abhängig und deshalb hat er
sich entschieden auf direktem
Konfrontationskurs mit Putins Dackeln zu
gehen wer hat die Entlassung von scheuge
und Erasmus gefordert und sich ständig
mit allen möglichen Bezeichnungen
beschimpft die allesamt viel schlimmer
waren als Dackel und da sich scheuge und
wir rassimo auf das offensichtlich nicht
gefallen lassen wollten sind wir dort wo
wir jetzt nun mal sind aber wartet mal
denn diese ganze Geschichte wirkt ein
paar Fragen auf warum handelte die Armee
einschließlich der Luftwaffe nicht
entschlossen und wurde auch nicht
eindeutig mobilisiert um den Push
zurückzuschlagen hatte der Camel Angst
dass eine der Version seine Befehle
missachten und sich auf die Seite der
Rebellen stellen könnte wenn die
Spannungen weiter zunehmen warum hat
Putin selbst die beiden am Morgen als
Verräter beschuldigt und gesagt sie
würden bestraft werden nur um sie
Stunden später ungeschoren davonkommen
zu lassen warum flog jetzt Präsidenten
Maschine mit seiner atomaren
Kommandozentrale egal ob mit ihm selbst
an Bord oder nicht aus Moskau nach St
Petersburg war sich der Kreml etwa nicht
sicher dass er Wagner leicht besiegen
könnte warum sollten sie überhaupt einen
Mittelsmann wie Luca Schenker brauchen
hatten sie Angst das Moskau oder
zumindest ein Teil der Hauptstadt
verloren gehen könnte was dann natürlich
eine politischen Gaudi Übergang mit
einem echten Bürgerkrieg bedeutet hätte
warum waren Putin und die übrigen
Spitzenbeamten der Regierung so weit weg
hat der Präsident Moskau wirklich aus
Angst vor dem was passieren könnte
verlassen traut er seinem inneren Kreis
nicht mehr wie ist es möglich dass die
bestätigt wurde der amerikanische
Geheimdienst seit Wochen über Wagners
Absichten Bescheid wusste während der
chemischer war ohne wirksame
Vorbereitung und überrumpelt wurde ist
der Informationsfluss der russischen
Geheimdienste schon dermaßen gestört
warum hat Deutschland zum Sturm auf
Moskau geblasen und es dann so kurz vor
dem Ziel umgekehrt hat er angesichts der
Aussicht auf einen katastrophalen Erfolg
die Nerven verloren ich meine eine Stadt
mit einer Truppe zu besetzen ist das
eine aber die Regierungsgewalt und
Verantwortung für eine wildes Land wie
Russland zu übernehmen ist schon etwas
anderes etwas wovor selbst hat gesagt
eine Züge gehört zurückschrecken dürften
wenn sich mit all den Moskau Oligarchen
und den regionalen Fürsten herumschlagen
und arrangieren zu müssen ist wahrlich
keinen Zuckerschlecken oder würdet ihr
Putins Job haben wollen hat vielleicht
auch die Unterstützung einer
regierungskritischen Fraktion gehofft
die sich am Ende aber nicht einstellte
us-offizielle sagen dass der russische
General surowicin von den
rebellionsplänen des Söldner Chefs
wusste ein hochrangiger russischer
General wusste im Voraus von
sich gegen die russische Militärführung
aufzulehnen general zu gehen ist ein
angesehener militärischer Führer der
nach der ukrainischen Gegenoffensive im
letzten Jahr dazu beigetragen hat die
Verteidigungslinien zu stärken er wurde
im Januar als Oberbefehlshaber abgelöst
behielt aber sein Einfluss auf die
Leitung der kriegs-operation und ist bei
den Truppen weiterhin beliebt pregorian
hatte während der russischen militärin
Dimension in Syrien mit generalführer
wegen zusammengearbeitet und ihn als den
fähigsten Kommandeur der russischen
Armee bezeichnet sowohl Generation haben
general geraten der in der Ukraine
angewandten Taktiken angegriffen
US-Quellen besagen das ist Anzeichen
dafür gibt das auch andere russische
generelle rigoris versucht die Führung
des Verteidigungsministeriums mit Gewalt
auszuwechseln unterstützt haben könnten
sie behaupten dass Brigitte sein
Aufstand nicht gestartet hätte ohne zu
glauben dass andere Führungskräfte in
Machtposition ihm zu Hilfe kommen würden
war das also auch der Fall bei und im
stellvertretenden
sie beide gaben recht merkwürdige
Erklärungen ab in denen sie pregoschin
aufforderten sich zurückzuziehen in
diesen Aufnahmen wirken sie irgendwie so
als wären sie gezwungen worden diese
Erklärungen abzugeben zum Zeitpunkt der
Aufnahme dieses Videos hörten wir von
vorläufigen Informationen das Turbo
Viking und sein Stellvertreter
Generaloberst du den festgenommen und in
das Untersuchungsgefängnis von Tabor
gebracht worden wären wir konnten die
Authentizität dieser Meldungen nicht zu
100% verifizieren aber das ganze sieht
schon sehr verdächtig aus fakt ist es
ist verdammt schwer zu erklären wie ein
tausende Mann sie in der zöllnertrupp
ungehindert eine Millionenstadt
inklusive Hauptquartier eine Armee die
Vision und Luftwaffenbasis besetzen kann
und anschließend 800 km weit quer über 4
russische Oblast befährt wenn es dafür
keine nennenswerte Unterstützung durch
die russische Bevölkerung und Generäle
innerhalb der Sicherheitsorgane gibt
putin war gezwungen seinen Partei Kadern
und Bürgermeister zu befehlen mit
Lastern Kippwagen und Baggern Barrikaden
zu errichten und Autobahnen aufzureißen
weil die regulären Streitkräfte dafür
nicht zur Verfügung standen die Armee
war Produkt präsent oder sie war nicht
dazu bereit Putins Regie zu verteidigen
die Frage lautet daher nicht ob
russische generelle brigoche die Daumen
gedrückt haben sondern wie viele daran
beteiligt waren damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen das heißt nicht dass
die pregorians Aktion mit geplant hätten
sondern dass Sie sie einfach ausgenutzt
haben es ist kein großes Geheimnis dass
viele Führungskräfte in Russland eine
neue Führung im Kreml gerne begrüßt
hätten nur selbst dafür den Kopf
erhalten wollen sie auch nicht
schließlich sind sie fast alle feige ja
keine mutigen Raubtiere denn genau das
ist ist was diese Leute im System Putin
nach oben gespült hat sie trauen sich
nicht selbst etwas unternehmen damit sie
nicht erwischt werden also warten Sie
bis etwas von alleine passiert und
nutzen es dann aus
Opportunisten so weit das Auge erreicht
einige von ihnen haben zu früh gehandelt
und wurden erwischt aber viele andere
haben lieber in ihren warmen Sesseln
darauf gewartet das Wagner Moskau
erreicht und ist bis Sonntag einnimmt
nach außen drückt diese ganze
Opportunisten Wandel immer noch
irgendwie loyal aber sie sind bereits
sofort zum nächstbesten starken Mann
über zu laufen wenn sich eine sichere
Gelegenheit dafür bietet aber wie gesagt
war pregoschin wohl nicht wirklich
scharf auf die ganz große macht er hat
dies doch auch immer wieder betont er
wolle nicht Putin stürzt sondern nur die
Köpfe von scheuge und gerassimov zuerst
hoffte er sie in Roßdorf während ihrer
Inspektionsreise im Hauptquartier des
jüdischen militärbeziehers kidnappen zu
können doch der FSB hatte ihn sowieso
erhöhte Alarmbereitschaft verordnet
aufgrund der in Anbetracht des
näherrückenden entwaffnungstermins von
Wagen am 01.07 zu erwarten Spannungen
der Chef der wagnergruppe hilft gegen
plante die Entführung von
russlandsführenden Militärs angeblich er
wurde FSB zwei Tage vor dem geplanten
Versuch von Gregor Schütz Plan der Chef
der russischen
nationaltorf sagte am Dienstag das ist
informations Lager über das komplette
gegeben habe gregorien gelang ist zwar
nicht Russlands oberste Militärs zu
entmachten aber seine Söldner eroberten
während der 36-stündigen Aktion ohne
großen Widerstand die südliche Stadt
Roßdorf in der sich eine wichtige
militärische Kommandozentrale befindet
schon guten Rasse also gut darauf
vorbereitet schnellstmöglich die Flug zu
ergreifen und sich in
Sicherheitsverwahrung zu begeben sollten
sich Ihnen die wagnertruppen irgendwie
auch das zeigt ja schon in welch
kritischer Lage sich das russische
Regime befindet und als sie pregorian
deswegen dort durch die Lappen gegangen
waren und Putin einfach nicht ans
Telefon gehen wollte dachte ich an
dieser Stelle natürlich dass ein Deal
bei dem er sein Leben und einen genügend
großen Kämpfer und Wagner als
Lebensversicherung behalten kann obwohl
erstmal gut genug sein oder zumindest
ein erheblicher Gewinn gegenüber dem was
ihm ohne seinen Aufstand gedroht hätte
nämlich die komplette Auflösung seiner
Macht Basis zum ersten Juli und das
anschließend vollkommene ausgeliefert
sein Gegenüber Putins Mordlust klar ist
all diese Details wird man erst im Laufe
der Zeit vollständig aufklären können
westliche Geheimdienste weisen jedoch
auf diese Theorie hin sie erklärt schon
ganz gut warum schon umgekehrt ist und
auch warum tut ihr nicht die
Streitkräfte mobilisieren und die sollte
direkt konfrontieren konnte fakt ist
existiert Strategie scheint so weit
aufzugeben solange Putin an der Macht
ist kann er zwar nicht wieder nach
Ausland zurückkehren aber seine Truppe
ist einigermaßen intakt er hat viele
Männer die seinen Ruf gefolgt sind und
hat genug Geld angehalten Orten
versteckt und Wagner weiter zu betreiben
dies wird seine Lebensversicherung sein
wenn pregoschuss unterordnungsbefehl
gefolgt oder in der Ukraine geblieben
wäre hätte Wagner aufgehört zu
existieren seine Männer wären an die
frontbeordert aber ohne Nachschub
abgeschlachtet worden pregorian erinnert
sich doch gut daran was ihnen 2018 ins
Syrien gegen die Amis passiert ist tja
und Putin hat nun zugegeben das Wagner
vollständig von der russischen Regierung
finanziert wird aber dazu später mehr
gut bedeutet das das Wagner ohne die
staatlichen Finanzspritzen aus dem
Grimmel aufhören wird zu existieren nur
klar ist das Weißrussland diese Rolle
nicht vollständig übernehmen kann dazu
hat es nicht genügend Mittel allerdings
kontrolliert Wagner immer noch Gold und
Diamanten Minen in Afrika und hat einige
Einnahmen aus Öl verkaufen in Syrien
diese Einnahmen fließend derzeit nach
Moskau aber das wird sich bald ändern
wenn moskaust Einfluss schwindet wer
macht Kampf zwischen Wagner und krabbel
ist also noch nicht zu Ende in seiner
nächsten Phase wird es um eben diese
Ressourcen geben
in Syrien angeblich inhaftiert während
Putin gegen waren da vorgeht die
Webseite berichtete am Dienstag die
russische Militärpolizei in
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Geheimdienstes
syrischen Regimes eine
verhaftungskampagne gegen Anführer
Mitarbeiter und rekrutierungsbeamter
durchgeführt hat die für die
wagnergruppe in Syrien Arbeiten vorerst
muss man jedoch sagen dass brigoche in
seinem Sinne vieles richtig gemacht hat
während Putin sich schon vorher in einen
Sackgasse in einer friert hatte in eine
Sackgasse in der er nur verlieren und
nicht gewinnen konnte sich immerhin
zwischen sicheren Tod und Flucht nach
vorne entscheiden Puten Entschuldigung
waren jedoch alle Optionen ausgegangen
sie handelten aus purer Verzweiflung
denn sie hatten nicht die absichtlich
für Sie wertvollen wagnerkämpfer aus der
Ukraine abzuziehen aber sie konnten es
sich auch nicht mehr leisten in jede 50
Millionen Dollar Monatsgehalt zu
überweisen die sie gewohnt waren wir
haben in unserem letzten Video darüber
gesprochen die einzige gigantischen
Finanz gehen mit rasanten temposition
neige der Grund dafür ist der Einbruch
der Öl und Gasexporte und die Explosion
der Ausgaben für den Krieg aber auch die
strauchelnde Wirtschaft ja und hatten
Angesicht dieser Lage die geniale Idee
die Kosten für die teuren waren einfach
drastisch zu kappen in können Sie als
billiges Soldaten in die reguläre Armee
aufgenommen werden okay soweit ihr Plan
klar es handelt es sich in jeder
Hinsicht um eine schreckliche
Entscheidung vor allem was die Moral der
Leute angeht aber Moskau hat keine
andere Wahl gehabt und alles was bei
Kreml nun tun kann ist die Konsequenzen
dieser Entscheidung bis zum bitteren
Ende durchzuhalten Wagner war ihre beste
Hoffnung auf einen Sieg aber natürlich
auch keine realistische wusste das schon
früh weder Wagner noch die russische
Armee haben eine Chance gegen eine
moderne Armee zu der sich die
ukrainische immer weiter formt der
springende Punkt ist das Putin sich
dessen nicht bewusst ist er glaubt immer
noch daran dass er gewinnen wird und
kann nicht verstehen was um ihn herum
passiert von daher treffen bringsch ins
Aussagen aus seinem randvideo durchaus
zu putin wird von allen belogen aber er
hat dies selbst so eingerichtet die Lüge
ist gewollt systemisch während pregoris
aufstand und auch im Nachhinein kamen
die wildesten und dümmsten
spekulationskonstrukte und
Verschwörungstheorien auf und ich will
euch die Zeit ersparen an dieser Stelle
über sie zu reden oder sie zu die Banken
sie sind mir wieder meine Mühe noch eure
Zeit wert schenkt den bregorian
Verschwörungstheorien nicht allzu viel
Glauben die einfachste Erklärung für das
Chaos an diesem Wochenende in Russland
ist wahrscheinlich die richtige
Verschwörungstheoretiker bestehen darauf
dass schattenhafte Kräfte am Werk sind
die den Lauf der Geschichte lenken und
gestalten aber die Geschichte die in der
westlichen Presse über die pregorian
Meuterei erzählt wird ist viel
glaubwürdiger auch wenn sie weitaus
schmutzige und banaler ist denn was
bringt euch schon am vergangenen
Wochenende getan hat war genau das nach
was es aussah er und Wagner wollten sich
einfach nicht den
Verteidigungsministerium unterordnen
also ergriffen sie die einzige
Möglichkeit die ihnen blieb sie führten
den Russen und der Welt ihre immense
Macht und zugleich die Machtlosigkeit
tut jetzt vor Augen diese Demonstration
hat wunderbar geklappt und jetzt lassen
Sie sich in Weißrussland nieder und
können zu einer echten Zöllner Firma
werden die außerordentlich
professionelle Besetzung Rostocks und er
war gemutige Vorstoß auf Moskau könnten
sogar für eine gewaltigen
reputationsboost unter potenziellen
Kunden gesorgt haben und so viel mehr
neuen Business für Wagner zum Beispiel
in Afrika führen eine bessere Werbung
für eine Söldnerfirma kann man sich wohl
kaum vorstellen und selbst Moskau hat
ein eminentes Interesse daran dass die
wagnertruppen in Afrika und dem Nahen
Osten weiterhin funktionieren und die
Frage ist ob dies ohne prägossen
überhaupt gehen wird Russland könnte
riskieren einen großen Teil seines
Einflusses in diesen Regionen zu
verlieren also auch wenn Putin jetzt mit
Korruptionsvorwürfen wie sagt und sein
Vermögen in Russland konfisieren wird um
sich selbst in besserem Licht da stehen
zu lassen der wagnerboss hat noch so
manchen Trumpf im Ärmel und er wird
genügend Geld gebunkert haben um jene
Kämpfer zu unterhalten die sein Leben
schützen werden ihr seht also das war
noch lange nicht das Ende der Geschichte
denn andererseits Diktatoren derart
herauszufordern führte selten zu einer
friedlichen Lösung denn es geht darum
Macht und Stärke zu demonstrieren und
bisher hat sich Gregorian als stärker
und Putin als schwächer erwiesen als
angenommen also muss Putin nun umso
stärker versuchen sein Image als starker
Mann wieder herzustellen und dazu wird
er natürlich versuchen zu demontieren
langsam aber sicher bring euch in wird
umgekehrt versuchen dem entgegenzuwirken
zum Beispiel indem er seine enorme
Popularität in der Bevölkerung die sich
zum Beispiel in Rostock offen gezeigt
hat weiter schürt und zum Einsatz bringt
schließlich sind ja wie gesagt nächstes
Jahr Wahlen in Russland auch wenn das in
einem Mafia stand natürlich was ganz
anderes bedeutet als in einem normalen
Staat aber ungeachtet dessen was letzte
Woche wirklich in den Köpfen der Herren
P&P vorging ihr offenes Machtspiel hat
unglaublich viele Wahrheiten deutlich
gemacht bzw sehr interessante
Vermutungen endgültig bestätigt und
diese neuen Gewissheiten haben die
Situation für Putin Russland die Ukraine
und die Welt Maas geht nicht verändert
aber fangen wir mit dem
offensichtlichsten an wie macht ihr ist
nun mal die Mafia welche Einigung auch
immer heute erzielt wurde es wurde Blut
vergossen und Putins Illusion der
Unbesiegbarkeit ist verflogen er und
seine kopane haben echte Angst
geschmeckt Moskau war bedroht ja so
sieht's aus Putins macht ist nicht mehr
das was sie in den Augen der Welt vor
dem 20 Juni zu sein schienen und meine
Lieben Zuschauer das ist erst der Anfang
wir bereiten gerade ein Video für euch
vor indem wir uns ansehen werden welche
Clans und macht Gruppierungen sich in
Russland bereits darauf vorbereiten die
Nachfolge Wladimir Putin zu übernehmen
wie Sie schon jetzt ihre messerwetzen
gegeneinander kämpfen und sich in
Stellung bringen also Abo nicht
vergessen um es ja nicht zu verpassen
das wird allerdings das übernächste
Video dieser Reihe sein denn morgen
schauen wir uns im zweiten Teil dieses
Videos erstmal an ob ihre Hoffnung auf
ein baldiges Ende der putinischen Ära
überhaupt gerechtfertigt ist was hat
sich mit brigochis Mutter Reihe an Punkt
den Status geändert aktiviert also schon
mal das Abo glücklich und schnallt Euch
dann gut an denn Morgen begeben wir uns
auf die stürmische Fahrt in eine neue
Realität und bis dahin könnt ihr euch im
Kommentarbereich beim Laufen so und
jetzt seid erstmal wieder ihr mit eurer
Meinung an der Reihe was denkt ihr über
den Staatsstreich der wagnergruppe wer
hat eurer Meinung nach mehr verloren
bringt euch einen oder Putin glaubt ihr
dass ich Putin von all seinen
Rückschlägen wird er holen können oder
war dies der Anfang von seinem Ende wie
wird sich das alles auf den Trick in der
Ukraine auswählen nun auch das werden
wir in künftigen Videos unter die Lupe
nehmen aber schreibt uns doch schon mal
was euch einfällt denn wie immer sind
wir schon auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like heißt
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
dem uns jetzt dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
vergesst bitte auch nicht das spannende
Online-Spiel unsere sponsers Konflikt
auf nations kostenlos auszuprobieren
wenn du dich liest und zuführen und über
militärische Strategien spekulieren
willst solltest du es unbedingt über den
Link in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video anspielen also macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]